[Musique]
la Réunion bienvenue
chez Monsieur la femme dans le siècle de
Zazie côté malade
sinon
mais pas que il fallait aussi un morceau
bonjour comment allez-vous
montrer
il y avait pas la lumière
la lampe pétrole et il fonctionne encore
oui jusqu'à là
en tout cas les chouettes mais pourquoi
ou là par la moindre la case ils tombent
bien on connaît notre émission c'est
notre case nous trésor Comment l'arrivée
présentement
là voilà d'accord
mon avis ou case les particularités
quand même exceptionnelle mais voilà la
paille
conseils
les maisons avec la pâte du vétuaire
mais tous les 5 ans pour renouveler ben
c'est mon vieux papa qu'elle a fait
monter aux gens voilà pour ça député
depuis la 12 ans de jambes et en train
de structures et nous on en a deux bois
aussi et ben Dubois particulier comment
dans la maison et dis-moi depuis le
temps où habite ici que c'est le
meilleur souvenir mon chemin
malade maintenant maintenant
le travail et puis je l'ai
ôté les chouettes alors dernière
question même bien posé mon émission
quel endroit on peut faire le plus ou de
cases j'ai une autre cuisine
la route quand les personnes
en tout cas mais vous les remets
votre case tu as trouvé bon allez salut
[Rires]
un magnifique trésor la lampe à pétrole
et un garagiste la case mais les pas
fini moi ça a continué bas de carrière
et d'autres trésor la roue alors toute
mon trésor ma beauté ma beauté
m'apprendre tes loquée à mon moment
ça m'a ensoleillé oui mon créateur